dear Aunt Lucy you sent me to London to
find a home I have a wonderful family I
think you're in great shape for a man
your age mr. Brown Wow Thank You
Paddington hang on how old do you think
I am oh about 80 and I've really got to
grips with how things work Mr Gruber
I mean I'd like to get my Aunt Lucy a
birthday present how about these ruling
shoes please Mr Gruber be serious
what's this this puppy book is the only
one of its kind and they want a lot of
money boring I'm going to get a job and
buy that book no window cleaner
Wow
[Music]
cheerio but if you cover hold it right
there oh but I'm not the thief we're
rich again round pay laundry you two
it's only one red sock what's the worst
that can happen
afternoon chaps I want to hear all about
the investigation Paddington is innocent
he's a master of disguise well this is
breaking and entering haven't broken
energy
[Applause]
[Music]
Paddington looks for the good in all of
us and somehow he finds it if we're kind
and polite the world will be right
[Music]
how
[Music]
you
you